hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
it's a 20 second of april and you're
tuned into games flat knees the fez der
is all set to launch their beta for the
Elder Scrolls online on PlayStation 4
and Xbox one tomorrow and here's
everything you need to know about that
the publisher have clarified that this
is a limited beta meaning you'll need an
invite to take part and just because
you've signed up to try it out doesn't
mean you'll be able to if you do happen
to get yourself in the beta officially
begins at ten a.m. EDT on the
twenty-third and ends at ten a.m. EDT on
Monday the 27th Bethesda have said
you're free to share screen shots and
livestream gameplay although it's worth
noting that beta progress won't carry to
the full version when it arrives in June
and the console beta doesn't support
cross-platform play if you're keen on
this one you'll probably want to get
your download started as early as
possible since the festa have said that
the install size could be more than 65
gigabytes that's maxing out a 50
gigabyte blu-ray disc Plus what Bethesda
anticipating will be a 15 gigabyte day
one patch the next game to get hit with
DLC drama is star wars battlefront but
EA dice have come out to dispel the
rumors addressing the reddit rumor mill
assistant producer just for Nielson said
quote if you think there's anything
we're not including in the game to save
it for DLC i can tell you you're one
hundred percent wrong he also commented
on speculation surrounding the battle of
jakku maps which is set to be released
after the game launches as free DLC
redditors suspected that this content
was held back for marketing purposes but
nielsen insists this wasn't the case
saying it was that the idea to do the
jackaroo maps can quite late in the
process and we didn't have capacity to
add them for launch so we found a way to
get them out to people as soon as
possible after launch finally destiny
has a new level cap as well as a bunch
of other new things thanks to the
upcoming house of wolves
l see a teaser trailer has clued us into
a few changes and bungie revealed more
during a live stream today players will
now be able to reach a light level of 34
which would mark a similar to level
increase as seen in the dark below the
new social space called the Reese was
announced which will house new npcs and
vendors new features set to be
introduced include the ability to
reforge perks for guns bring old weapons
up to the new damage caps and
all-purpose material exchange and a
bunch of new ships weapons and armor
obviously let me know down in the
comments if you're interested in the
house of wolves dlc and why or why not
you can have the game spot where we've
got stories on Halo 3 ODST HD coming to
master chief collection and the
announcement of total war warhammer that
is everything I have for you today as
always let me know what you cared about
and i'll catch you same time tomorrow
you